this is cod 309 165 nine broadcasting on
all frequencies if there are any other
survivors out there let me know I'm so
glad you're awake
I've been rather bored without you you
know what I'm like I start to get a
little existential when I don't have
someone to care for take your time I
think you're going to have a big day
ahead of you how long have we been on
this planet now 385 days
where's Lika got to why don't you try
calling it like a that beast is up in
its home hiding from shame I'd imagine
I'm afraid we have some work to do
before you can play with your pet best
you take a look around
ah the Wix yes our power problem is
affecting this too we won't be able to
fix much if we can't lift heavy objects
you see here the water turbines clogged
that's the cause of the power outage all
that roughhouse dinosaur play it must
have tipped these barrels into the water
excellent we have power but I can see
now that the circuits need repairing
tools Oh wonderful
I can actually help you with that
why don't you show some
[Music]
look at this date of this thing to think
we've spent so long trying to keep
dinosaurs out of our camp and now we've
gone I've let one in let's fix the
Scarecrow it's going to need two arms a
head and a hat to be useful the
multi-tool will fix this up in no time
[Music]
very good
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
trapped by a big piece of mess what a
shame
[Music]
come on Lika don't worry about Higgs I
just got to work on your training so he
doesn't blow a fuse oh there it is get
it to drop that ball before it destroys
the thing like we can buy another one
[Music]
release now big test can it remember how
to play hide and seek head over to the
tree there and start the game come on
ready or not here I come
[Music]
warmer and warmer what does it got there
that is a Higgs unit get your head away
from there for some serious damage is
done there's precious data in there we
should scan it immediately Robyn
precious information thank you
we don't just know to the camp your
friend must have brought him here there
are tooth marks on the panels these guys
built a whole landing site if our crew
are out there that's where they'd start
the colony these Higgs units can tell us
where they are there must be more let's
find them
[Music]